we have a voicemail number and that
number is
2192 David P I mentioned Jewish
Christmas which is of course you get
Chinese or Indian food or really any
place that's open right it just tends to
be Asian restaurants
um and there's a caller who is not
thrilled with the Indian food component
of it take a listen to this David down
from Jersey and watching the show today
and you're saying that the Jewish
Christmas is Chinese or Indian food
correct I'm like do you not understand
the meaning of the season the Christmas
spirit how could you
it's just like Jesus died for our sins
David and this is the day we celebrate
his birth not by Indian food I mean
that's the most ridiculous thing I've
ever heard everyone knows it's Chinese
food and a movie date the Chinese food
and a movie never Indians but I don't
know you can do Indian food the rest of
the year but this day Jesus died so we
could have the day off for our movie and
Chinese food okay and specifically it
has to be like maybe Avatar too okay and
we're now getting a little bit too
detailed so this is a joke I don't think
that guy's really mad that I had Indian
food on Christmas but yes there's a long
tradition there's in fact a lot of
interesting
um uh sort of like articles and Research
into this how did it end up that Jewish
folks get Asian food on Christmas and of
course the answer is relatively simple
Christmas is really boring if you're
Jewish I remember from when I was a kid
now it's less boring because no matter
what day it is I'm just chasing around a
baby but that that's a different story
but historically it's a very boring day
um and you order from the restaurants
that are open
and uh typically those are Asian
restaurants of different kinds I believe
Indian food is just as acceptable as
Chinese food on Christmas if you
disagree with me you can let me know we
have a fantastic bonus show for you
today oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad well
we'll see if any money is made today on
today's bonus show we are going to talk
about the Supreme Court saying the
trump-era Border restrictions under
title 42 will remain in effect while
legal challenges play out very
controversial very hypocritical much of
what's gone on with title 42 we will
talk about it a bill forcing the feds to
fix prison cameras has been signed into
law prison cameras are actually a big
topic and I recently actually read a
book
um about prisons and we're going to talk
about the prison cameras there's
actually quite a connection to police
body cameras as well there which we will
discuss and then lastly it has been
revealed that Donald Trump didn't
realize that the White House schedule
was a public document until there were
only weeks left of his presidency he
then realized wait a second what I'm
doing daily gets published and at that
point he asked for a much uh more
generic version to be published and
that's when you might remember in the
last few weeks of Trump's presidency his
schedule started to say things like the
president will have many meetings with
various people and work for the American
people
and we wondered that's really weird why
are they doing that it's clearly that
Trump isn't working
um he only learned then
that the president's official schedule
is a public document which is just
mind-blowing all of those stories and
more today on the bonus show when
producer Pat joins me remember get the
free white paper on how to argue
politics with people without burning the
bridge of the relationship with them
there's a free guide it's free it's
really free I'm not selling you anything
you can find it at davidpackman.com
guide davidpackman.com
slash guide it's free we'll see you on
the bonus show and back here tomorrow